hey how's it going everyone welcome back
to this crash course series in this
JavaScript tutorial I'm gonna be going
over how to do some basic Dom
manipulation in JavaScript what we'll do
is understand what the Dom is first of
all make sure we understand how to
access it I'll cover how to both modify
the existing page and how to insert new
elements into the page with JavaScript
and finally we'll build a small example
app using all of this together now feel
free to skip this section if you feel
like you already know all of this but it
might serve as a good refresher now that
you've started doing JavaScript at this
point you must have heard the acronym
Dom thrown around a bit and it stands
for document object model and it's
essentially the API for webpages when
you're on a page you can access the Dom
via JavaScript for example giving you
access to what are called Dom nodes now
the DOM is a tree structure and you can
see when you're writing HTML let's just
write some HTML here so real quick it's
a go here so HTML HTML notice how I
create a opening tag and a closing tag
head body
so your code might look like this where
you've got these elements like HTML here
and between the beginning and the end of
the element you've got more elements so
between the opening and closing of HTML
you've got all of these elements you can
tease out the tree structure pretty
straightforward from this but let's draw
it to just make it clear see you've got
this HTML node here at the top and it
acts like the parent for everything and
it has two children a head in a body
node and the head node also has a child
the title node you can kind of see the
structure and you look back at the code
you can kind of remember that this
follows the structure of the code now at
a high level this is how the page is
structured the Dom structures the
document or page like a tree with each
node containing objects data that kind
of thing and via JavaScript you have
programmatic access to the Dom tree that
gives you enormous flexibility in
modifying whatever you want in there
from JavaScript you can modify elements
on the page
destroy them create them basically
completely alter the look of the page
everything from the content and style of
individual items on the page to just
wholesale and serving your own elements
is up to you you can pretty much alter
whatever you want that in a nutshell is
what the DOM is and there's a ton of
methods that allow you to manipulate and
create items going through all of them
would be overwhelming and pretty
unnecessary what I'll do here is
introduce you to a couple really useful
ones we'll go over what they do and then
we'll build out a smaller example using
everything now together afterwards so
what I'll show you now is how to get an
element how to modify it and how to
create a new one and that'll allow us to
create a simple to-do list afterwards so
let's just get started go back to the
jas page so the first step is get
element by ID
and the way you use it is something like
this document done this allows you to
get an element by its ID so you have to
go and specify an ID for an element and
now you can find it really easily using
this method that'll allow you to read
its properties modify it pretty much do
whatever you want with it
now that's not the only way to get an
element from the Dom tree there's a few
more I'll show you another one real
quick since it's pretty common so
there's this one query selectors which
is a bit more advanced and but you'll
see it around it's similar to get
element by ID it goes and looks for a
single element but the first argument is
a CSS selector and it just goes and
finds the first thing that matches now
if you're not familiar with CSS
selectors just ignore this for now we're
not going to use it in the demo but you
should at least know what it does so now
if we want to create an element we can
do this there's create element oops and
this allows you to create a new element
and you just specify the type you want
so you can do something like and that'll
create a new div there's a somewhat
related create function as well called
create text note so I'll just go and
show you that and what that does is it
creates a text node and then you can
insert that into the page as well next
up is appendchild so this method lets
you insert another element as a child of
the one that you've got so what you do
is you call it on one so let's say that
you have the body and you go body dot
attend child and you insert that div
that you created a few lines up there
this will insert a new div into the page
and you'll actually be able to see it
over there in the elements tab in the
developer tools the last thing that's
worth mentioning is what's called
in event handler so let's just go and
show you that real quick so let's say
you have that div and you want to you
want to be called whenever someone
clicks on it so you can go div dot on
click equals now what we've done here is
we've assigned the on click handler on
the div element to a function expression
and you can go and write some code in
there so every time someone clicks on
that specific div on the page your code
will execute now sometimes you also see
this a different way now sometimes
you'll see this as an event listener
instead of assigning directly to on a
click or something like that and they're
functionally pretty similar so you can
just call it like this and I can best
apply my function expression in here and
in those two cases they will act pretty
much the same at least for our purposes
there are some differences between the
two but for our purposes they're pretty
much the same thing you can see that we
actually haven't covered a whole lot of
things here today we've only covered get
element by ID create element create text
node append child and on click but just
with those few methods we'll be able to
build something interesting now I'm
gonna go and delete all of this now
let's go build this out and we're pretty
much gonna stick with everything that
we've learned in this tutorial or in
previous tutorials in this series so
there should be 0 new functionality
shown here what we're doing is tying a
bunch of things together from the
previous tutorials
that means we're just going to use
variables functions and the dumb methods
that we went over today but that should
be enough to do what we want to do now
the first thing we need to do is go and
modify our HTML a little bit so let's go
over here and since we're gonna do a to
do list what we want is a button and an
input let's just go and make those
now we go and refresh we should see
those and we need somewhere to put all
of the to-do items so let's just go here
we want to be able to use get element by
ID so that we can manipulate these Dom
elements so we're gonna have to give IDs
to everything just go here I'm gonna
call this input input in kit know and
we're going to call this list that
should be fine
now this point that page still doesn't
do anything so we can go here and
hitting add nothing happens first thing
we want to do is get each of the
elements that we're going to be using so
let's go here
I think I call it inputs and we want to
get the button so add and the last thing
is we want the list because we want to
be appending children to this list now
the general flow here is that when you
type something in this field here and
hit the Add button we want to intercept
the event we want to intercept the click
event and when you want to do some code
in there so let's just go and add an
event handler for the button on clicked
like I showed you now by console dot log
in here you can see that our code is
running now let's make it do something
interesting now I could use a table I
could use the li elements I'm just going
to create a bunch of divs with text and
checkbox items in there so let give
equals
maybe want some text and create a spin
and in the span we're going to add the
text that was inside the input here in
this input field and now we create a
check box last thing we need to do is
put the check box in the text as
children of the div and then we need to
insert the div into the list and you'll
start to see it popping up on the page
now if I only do this you're not going
to see anything so we'll go reload the
page even though I type something in and
hit add you can see that nothing's
showing up on the page yet what we need
to do is insert it into the list
otherwise it's not going to do anything
now that we've inserted this it should
show up on the page but it's not gonna
look right the check boxes and actually
check box yet we're gonna have to do
some tweaking afterwards but let's just
go check it out and you can see that
this new element was created we can go
here and second and so it's kind of
working
so let's go customize the check box now
so that it looks like a check box go
back here
that should be enough and there we go we
had to and you got working checkboxes
now the last thing that we want to do
though is we want the style here to
change a little bit we don't want this
just to show up as text but maybe we
want to line through it and in order to
do that we need to change the style on
this text here the way that we can do
this is that we can add a handler to the
check box to each of these check boxes
and what that handler will do is it'll
check whether or not the check box is
checked and if it's checked it'll modify
the style and add a strikethrough on it
let's just go and do that now what I've
done here is I've set the unchanged
handler and whenever the checkbox state
has changed my function will call and so
we'll be able to do something if the
checkbox is checked we're gonna modify
the style we're gonna modify the text
decoration style to add a line through
and if it's not checked then we won't
add anything so that it doesn't get a
slash through it I go here reload just
one ad that's just added a few more
though
and check and check and uncheck and
there we go
we've tied together a few things we've
learned up until this point so functions
variables and a few Dom methods and we
were able to create a simple to-do list
without too much trouble
hopefully this example was easy to
follow if not let me know in the
comments where clarifications could be
made or if you just want to follow up on
something and that about wraps up
today's tutorial see you again soon
Cheers